des dépotoirs à ciel ouvert sont offerts
agricole je pensais jamais trouvé
quelque chose de gros comme ça qui sont
les bons et les méchants dans cette
guerre des sols contaminés s'est
déversée par n'importe qui n'importe
comment
effectivement j'ai côtoyé l'occasion les
jeunes ce crime organisé mais j'ai aucun
lien avec les jeunes sur leur disais ça
c'est un des chantiers où est-ce qu'ils
vont éventuellement construire des
condos présentement sont en train de
faire l'excavation
elle s'appelle marlène girard nous
sommes au début de l'hiver 2016 il y a
trois ans elle nous fait faire la
tournée des chantiers de construction à
montréal
le les sols sont très contaminée c'est
sûr parce que tout ce secteur là avant
c'est une zone industrielle
marlène girard et la présidente
d'énergie carboneutre une entreprise
spécialisée dans la décontamination des
sols
on va retrouver du métal on va retrouver
de la brique du béton des scories à
l'occasion parce que c'est des anciennes
usines puis il va avoir les
hydrocarbures aromatiques polycycliques
et ses dérivés du pétrole mais c'est
plus lourd
la femme d'affaires veut nous convaincre
qu'il y a un gros problème dans
l'industrie des sols contaminés
plus un prix d'excavation à n'ont rien
on est à un niveau d'excavation jamais
vu et la majorité des sites pour le
traitement des sols contaminés sont
moins occupé qu'avant donc les seuls
s'en vont ailleurs quelque chose qui
font qu'il ya quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas marlène girard voulez
savoir qui obtenait les contrats qui lui
échappait c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
décidé de n'en avoir le coeur net le
pilote on a mis une équipe de filature
sur le dossier ces détectives privés ont
surveillé des chantiers de construction
du centre ville et suivi des camions qui
en sortaient et un camion qui va être
chargé serait prête à gager que si on
suivait ce que mios là présentement et
nous mènerait probablement une terre
agricole
on est sûr que des sols contaminés ici
si on a les chantiers année sur les
terres agricoles on trouverait de la
contamination sur les terres agricoles
dans les derniers jours on observait
saint lumine lapierre ville est fière
saint-hilaire on a découvert un
stratagème qui a pris des proportions
énormes
et ce à chaque jour le nombre grandit ça
veut dire qu'à chaque jour les terres
agricoles du québec et de l'est de
l'ontario deviennent des dangers publics
ça se retrouve dans les cours d'eau ça
se retrouve dans l'air et ça se retrouve
dans notre assiette
trois ans se sont écoulés depuis notre
rencontre avec marlène girard et on
creuse de plus belle le centre ville de
montréal
une autre entreprise de décontamination
nous appellent pour sonner la leyre
c'est réellement le fait de perdre du
projet c'est vraiment le fait de voir
des projets nous échapper comme ça on se
dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe à l'est
robichaud & co présidents dans globe un
joueur majeur de la décontamination au
québec juste part de marché de montréal
je pense que c'est plusieurs centaines
de milliers tentent qui disparaissent
maintenant
par année englobe nous dit les mêmes
choses que nous disait marlène girard
trois ans plus tôt des sols contaminés
irait dans la nature surtout que dans
les centres autorisés
retournons en 2016 après avoir écouté la
femme d'affaires nous avons voulu
vérifier ces affirmations
nous avons suivi des camions arpenter
des terres agricoles 6 à 5 pétrole effet
analysé les échantillons de terre
certains étaient contaminés d'autres pas
mais nous avons frappé un mur dans notre
enquête
comment s'assurer que notre échantillon
venaient précisément d'un des camions
nous avions vu quitter un chantier de
construction centre-ville nous avons mis
notre reportage sur la glace en
apprenant que la sûreté du québec
conquête à la presse a publié une série
d'articles notamment avec certains
détails de cette enquête
mais malgré deux ans et demi de travail
de là est ce qu la direction des
poursuites criminelles et pénales a
décidé de ne pas attenter de poursuites
criminelles contre de présumés pollueurs
qui aurait déversé massivement des sols
contaminés dans la nature c'est qu'apple
dpcp nopo porter d'accusations dans ce
dossier locker on se dit au forum a été
peu plus proactifs et parce que
ces peuples concernés allaient robichaud
dans globe fait donc comme marraine
girard de carboneutre trois ans plus tôt
voulu aller chercher certaines dépenses
puis pour nous engager les inquiète a
qui ont suivi des camions quand même ces
détectives ont filmé les camions au
cours du printemps et de l'été 2010 8
des chantiers fortement pollués au
centre-ville des camions qui font
l'aller-retour plusieurs camions par
jour et qui vont dans les endroits qui
ne sont pas connus pour autoriser et qui
sont clairement des chargés dans des
milieux leveaux englobe nous a donné une
copie des vidéos
nous visionnons une première filature
des camions partent de chantier de
construction à montréal
les camions roulent vers l'ouest
pendant plus d'une heure ils prennent la
sortie pointe-fortune enfin et dont sur
ce chemin
ils se rendent au fond de la terre
[Musique]
nous sommes au milieu des champs à un
jet de pierre de la frontière ontarienne
presque au bord de la rivière des
outaouais
c'est là que les camions déversent leur
chargement puis il retourne à montréal
se faire charger à nouveau
nous savons que beaucoup de camions
déverser leurs contenus ici les
détectives dans le globe en ont suivi
des 10
pendant les sept jours de surveillance
des voisins ont dit avoir vu des
centaines de camions tout l'été
et on remblais ici depuis près de six
ans ces photos satellite montrent que le
propriétaire à remblayer sans permis ce
grand plan d'eau dès l'été 2013
[Musique]
à la fin de l'automne nous sommes allés
sur place nous avons vu d'imposantes
quantité de terre des débris çà et là où
tout vient tout ce qui a été déversé ici
depuis six ans le propriétaire du que ça
vient de différents chantiers
il dit qu'il n'a accepté que des sols
propre sur son terrain il assure qu'il a
tous les rapports pour le prouver
mais il refuse de nous les montrer à
propos du plan d'eau le propriétaire ni
la voix remblayer il raconte que des
barrages de castors avait provoqué
l'inondation de son terrain il a fait
rater les castors et le plan d'où ce
serait à sécher tout seul selon lui
[Musique]
les vidéos n'englobe montrent qu'une
partie de ces soldes est versée l'été
dernier viennent d'ici le projet des
condos q8 à la salle michel bélanger
avocat spécialisé en environnement
connaît bien le terrain sur lequel sont
construits les condos à ma connaissance
est un des six parmi les plus pollués
sur la région de montréal
ils étaient suivis je pense que
plusieurs rapports de contamination
furby 30 40 dernières années le pion
battistella différents endroits sur le
site qui avait la contamination
importante
et pour cause le terrain sur lequel est
présentement bâti le projet e cubitt
était occupé au 20e siècle par cette
usine là la salle coque elle produisait
un dérivé du charbon et plusieurs
produits chimiques
c'est réservoir contenait du goudron et
de la créosote d'autres usines se sont
succédé sur le même site
la docteure qu'aimer cause puis ladom
faire nous avons parlé aux promoteurs
des combos il nous a assuré qu'il a tous
des contaminés dans les règles de l'art
et que les sols que nous observons dans
ses camions sont parfaitement propre
des camions sortis du site des condos q8
nous ont également permis de découvrir
ce qui se passe sur cette terre agricole
dorment stands en montérégie
le propriétaire n'a pas de permis pour
remblayer et nous admet qu'il permet
gratuitement à plusieurs entreprises de
venir décharger chez lui il ne sait pas
d'où vient quoi ces zones agricoles ya
pas de l'assemblée nationale
mais compte tenu que les débris viennent
de plusieurs sites de la venue du
propriétaire
on ne peut blâmer les promoteurs des
condos au cul et qui nie avoir déversé
autre chose que des sols propres
[Musique]
nous commençons à comprendre pourquoi
les enquêtes échouent les unes après les
autres et pourquoi il est si difficile
de prouver la provenance de la pollution
mais nous n'avions rien vu
[Musique]
après la pause on découvre des battoirs
à ciel ouvert au milieu d'un champ de
l'est dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le brouillard est dense ce matin sur
cette route de campagne montérégie nous
allons voir un autre lieu où des camions
déverser leur chargement juillet et en
août dernier c'est du moins ce qu'on a
pu voir sur les vidéos des détectives
embauché par englobe on y voit des
camions partis d'autres chantiers au
centre ville de montréal
les détectives qui suit jusqu'à saint
rémi en montérégie
elie camions empruntent ce chemin de
terre disparaissent
on voit du mail sa droite ce qui
m'étonne c'est qu'on s'envoie toujours
trompé sans milieu agricole
c'est rémy est un haut lieu de la
culture maraîchère au québec en raison
de ses riches terres noires à la fin de
l'automne
nous utilisons un drone pour aller voir
ce qui se cache derrière les arbres
surplombant les champs d'étude
un dépotoir à ciel ouvert
[Musique]
si allant à pied des montagnes de terre
des briques des tuyaux de métal et
plastique des fils électriques et un
assortiment d'autres déchets tout ça au
milieu des terres agricoles
c'est clairement un dépôt sauvage mais
de matériaux secs qui devraient être
envoyés à la
avant le dénivelé avec la terre agricole
après c'est certain qu'il ya des sols
contaminés là dedans ça c'est cause
directement dans les sols agricoles
juste à côté
et justement voyez l'eau qui s'y colle
sur le site
[Musique]
un signe assez apparent qui ont
probablement d'autres choses que des
débitmètres ce n'est pas surprenant que
le ministère de l'environnement et
trouver des sols contaminés
ici au début de l'été dernier d'où
viennent ces tas de débris au milieu des
terres agricoles d'un des plus
importants producteurs maraîchers de la
région
nous retournons voir les vidéos on voit
très bien que les camions étaient
chargés ici boulevard rené lévesque ou
centre-ville de montréal
un gros contrats publics exécuté par
pomerleau
c'est le chantier de l'hôpital saint-luc
qui fait place au nouveau chum
une imposante démolition
déchets devrait être sorti du chantier
est normalement envoyé dans un centre
autorisé mais c'est ici à sare et mick
des tas de briques de l'hôpital saint
luc ont été déversés nous appelons le
propriétaire de la terre agricole benoit
barbeau de l'entreprise le maraîcher à
barbeau et 6
il nous dit que c'est parfaitement légal
qu'il se fait un fonds pour construire
un bâtiment
c'est pas parce que le propriétaire
voudrait construire une grange que ça
justifie d'y mettre n'importe quoi
benoit barbeau dit aussi que tout vient
du chantier de l'hôpital
sur ce chantier ces chantiers de placer
le jeu pas les condamne au chaos si ben
non on fait un fonctionnement avec butch
d'hasselt surtout vous êtes certains que
j'ai pas de salles qui sont venus
d'ailleurs je les appelle nous lui est
donc nous avons des images des camions
par du chantier du conte 12 nos cadences
griffin times et qui déchargent sur sa
terre agricole il change alors sa
version bombe à luz pour le béton la
table c'est autre chose ça venait
d'ailleurs donc exact et latin venez
d'où madame est servie de plusieurs
places là tant qu'on peut rentrer des
milliers de tonnes de terre venu de
plusieurs chantiers plus une partie des
débris l'hôpital saint luc benoit
barbeau a surtout tout est propre
je les ai tout le moins des 2 août ou
deviennent les seuls avec des jeux tout
cela mais le tuer mais benoit barbeau
refusera de nous montrer quoi que ce
soit par contre pomerleau a accepté de
nous rencontrer pour parler des débris
de l'hôpital saint-luc l'environnement
est une préoccupation
de pomerleau vincent martel est chargé
du projet il dit que tout a été fait
dans les règles
on compte le plus possible de valoriser
lorsque possible les débris de
démolition il dit que les débris
serviront à faire des chemins sur la
terre du maraîcher et que c'est une
bonne réutilisation confronté au fait
que la terre de saint rémy n'est pas
autorisée pour recevoir ces débris il
renvoie la balle aux sous traitants en
charge de la démolition
d'abord c'est pas la responsabilité de
l'entrepreneur faut être clair que ya
une entente contractuelle avec nos sous
traitants dans laquelle on le transforme
nos responsabilités même discours si
dave mayville le promoteur des condos
noka par écrit il remet la
responsabilité à ses sous-traitants pour
l'état peut pas se laver les merdes à
moi j'ai signé un contrat avec le plus
bas soumissionnaire la responsabilité de
maire selon la loi sur le générateur
hull déchets celui qui reçoit un seul
doit avoir également les autorisations
pour l'heure ce bras mais qui organise
ces déversements de sols contaminés et
de débris de construction qui sont les
vrais vilain de l'histoire
retournons voir ce que marlène girard et
d'autres sources vous disais il y a
trois ans et est arrivé un nouveau
joueur dans le marché qui prétend être
courtier à un seul comptait mener et
c'est des gens qui de toute évidence
n'ont pas de permis
le joueur en question s'appelait gestion
aux efforts environnement gestion ou est
fort l'une des entreprises suspecte dans
l' enquête de la sûreté du québec se
doit aussi s'est terminée sans
accusation criminelle
cela nous a quand même appris qu'un
certain louis pierre lafortune
travaillait chez gestion au efa un nom
connu qui a fait l'objet de plusieurs
reportages ou bien la fortune est connu
du milieu policier
il a été accusé notamment de blanchiment
d'argent et de gagne terrain
louis pierre lafortune a été condamné en
2016 pour complot pour recycler les
produits de la criminalité
il est toujours en appel du verdict nous
retournons voir les vidéos des
détectives dans globe beaucoup de
camions de la même entreprise car elle
mainville qui travaille maintenant chez
qu'à elle-même ville louis pierre
lafortune la sphère semble entendue
les villains clairement identifiés nous
allons les confronter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment tout serait plus simple si le
monde était noir et blanc avec des bons
et des méchants
cet homme c'est l'un des méchants selon
tout ce que nous avons entendu jusqu'à
présent et nous conduit sur ces routes
de la région mirabel et de l'eau côté
losc on voit les lettones loin du chemin
l'environnement envie de le fermer à
l'automne est un entrepreneur de
montréal qui me déverser ici avec une
paille contaminée
lui s'est fait prendre sur le champ en
arrière de la grange qu'on voit la bo
serge mainville est propriétaire de
kahel mainville entreprises de
camionnage en vedette dans les vidéos de
filature serge mainville est formel ce
n'est pas son entreprise qui fait des
déversements seul contaminés il soutient
qu'il en sait long là dessus dont le
truc des dons à coupant ses président
pendant baqouba c'est que inox
improvisions d'état
de remplissage qui ont besoin de
remplissage qui vont voir les
entrepreneurs puissent vendre des
coupons à peu près à monsieur tout le
monde en dix à trente pièces car en
pièces ou vainqueur du voyage ne sait
pas que jusqu à quel prix qui peuvent
aller des sols revient de où ils savent
à peu près pas parce que les sols sont
contaminés ils savent à peu près pas eu
aucun suivi social ils n'ont pas cru bon
ça c'est ça qui fait qu'on est pointé du
doigt
serge mainville en a gros sur le coeur
contre les grandes compagnies
décontamination et de disposition des
sols qui croit-il font beaucoup de
tapage pour s'assurer d'un quasi
monopole et monter les prix confronté
aux vidéos tournées par les détectives
dans globe
voici sa réponse ce n'est nullement ma
responsabilité de savoir ce qu'on
transporte en tant que tel on est comme
un taxi entre les deux on est payé pour
faire le chargement au point à aller au
point b c'est le client qui choisit le
qu'est-ce qui mène en camion et ses
clients choisie ou fait ça sera disposé
l'entrepreneur pense que sa croissance
rapide dérange le marché et que ses
compétiteurs multiplié les plaintes est
celui qui attire les enquêtes comme un
aimant si son consultant louis pierre
lafortune des pains depuis dix ans comme
un proche des avengers il a accepté de
nous donner sa première entrevue à la
caméra effectivement je connaissais des
gens du crime organisé
j'ai côtoyé l occasion aussi les gens du
crime organisé mais ça fait quand même
10 15 ados et à ce moment là c'était un
autre temps autres moeurs
c'était pas ou à tout le moins pour moi
tellement grave de côtoyer des gens ce
crime organisé
ce qui a vraiment changé la perception
dans ma perception de la perception des
gens général fait que j'ai eu avec les
gens nous le confronterons nombreuses
sources qu'il accuse d'avoir organisé de
la dispersion est légal de sols
contaminés
j'étais pieds dans la discussion de sol
c'est vrai je nie totalement d'avoir été
impliqué dans les discussions de sols
contaminés illégalement non ce match on
fait pas partie des actions je suis
conso pie xii est la même que à cause
effective demain convient toujours bon
penser j'ai peu joué des plus parfaits
que parfait avec ceux qui se plaignent
c'est probablement des entreprises
compétitrice qui souhaite ardemment
tweed compter mais même si le pot
il reconnaît que certains rejettent des
contaminants dans la nature mais il
croit que ce phénomène est négligeable
et que cet épouvantail est agité par les
entreprises de décontamination et les
lieux d'enfouissement autorisée c'est
une question d'heure je lui interdis tx2
sol qui sort par année et c'est un
cartel préserver qsssl partage fait la
dernière chose qu'ils veulent c'est que
quelqu'un d'autre dans cette industrie
conclusion tout le monde reconnaît qu'il
ya un problème dans l'industrie des sols
contaminés mais tous ne s'entendent pas
sur la cause
nous avons visité plus de sites que nous
avons pu vous en montrer et chaque fois
c'est la même chose
la compagnie qui transporte n'est pas
responsable du dieu de dispositions
le promoteur d'où viennent les sols dit
que tout est conforme
mais si ce ne l'est pas c'est la faute
des sous traitants quand la police
enquête pas d'accusations criminelles et
sur un autre site le ministère
l'environnement n'ont même pas été
capables de donner une amende aux
suspects et procédures ont été cassés
pour délais déraisonnables de la
poursuite et le ministre de
l'environnement benoît charette a refusé
une entrevue pour ce reportage
invoquant des enquêtes qui seraient en
cours de l'avis de plusieurs le
ministère de l'environnement ne fait
peur à personne
dans tout dossier environnement tout ça
fait des années que j'en fais c'est
toujours la même chose tombe avant les
meilleures lois thobois volet meilleure
sanction les peines les plus sévères si
tu ne les exercent pas si tu ne les
appliquent pas ça donne rien en fait
celle-ci message inverse que sa licence
en allez-y de toute façon aux sanctions
de position sanctions risquent de pas
beauty ou encore ça soit pas très
coûteux pour vous c'est plus payant de
contrevenir à la loi que de s'y
conformer
en bout de ligne nous avons trouvé dans
la région de montréal et dans l'est de
l'ontario des dépotoirs à ciel ouvert en
pleine nature est absolument personne
qui reconnaît sa responsabilité
[Musique]